titanfall from respawn and entertainment
they're coming out on Xbox one PC next
week and then on xbox 360
two weeks later I am very very happy to
be sitting here with the creator of that
videogame the creeper from minecraft
which I'm very happy to say we didn't
stick on the green-screen it's a
pleasure to have you today here sir
should we is your mic still in the right
place yeah sure it's perfect I like it
sir how are you doing doing well last
time I still warm in there yeah it gets
it's only gonna get warmer don't worry
about it they made me sitting there for
hours the last time I saw you it was a
week before the beta started and what's
it like being on the opposite side of
that because before we were no one a
very few people that seen the game or is
now about two million people of beta
that's true
the response to the beta was great you
know we found a few problems early on
that we that we fixed so we're in better
shape for launch that's always good a
lot of people got to play it a lot of
positive response coming out of it so
we're pretty excited pretty happy were
you anticipating a type of response or
positive you know optimistic cautiously
optimistic about it or yeah always hope
for that right now
so yeah I mean we we wanted that type of
response to get that many people through
you know we were hoping we didn't you
know crash everything we ended up
filling the servers we had limited
capacity for beta but we wanted to fill
them at the end there and just to see
what would happen how things were
handled at max capacity and that went
well it's like 2 million people in total
done in the ends it was it was about 2
million people that got through not
simultaneously but you know the whole
course of the beta did you expect to
have it that big because at the start it
seemed to be like this this gold rush of
can I get titanfall codes and then at a
certain point it was like when the ruble
debased they just became worthless
because it was an open beta then well I
was the planner well we all we wanted to
always get as many people through as
possible yeah it's just about capacity
and kind of pushing people through in a
manner that you know we can test things
so you know the goal was to see how many
people you know we didn't know with
Friday being Valentine's Day Monday
being a holiday we didn't know what our
fall-off was if everybody stayed and
played the entire time
you know without sleeping we'd have been
able to get less people too so
fortunately people passed out at some
point to get other people in to replace
them and cycle in as many as possible
did you see people drop off on
Valentine's Day to spend time with their
loved ones or video game people just the
worst part you know I think we had
that's when the servers were down for
about seven hours on Friday and yes you
know I don't think it was coincidence I
think it was somebody spouse that paid
somebody off to know to have that error
happen so I'm still going with that one
what is a what is the beta taught you
guys about the capacity for these
servers going into the full launch a lot
about load balancing and you know
there's certain like when you're in a
lobby server and really what your what
your thing is doesn't matter so we can
kind of shuffle them around based on
like you know there's different peak
times for different places yeah so we
now say okay you know we can put a lobby
server on us somewhere where it's you
know a little higher pain but it doesn't
matter and then when you do the game
server those are reserved on areas that
peak capacity and this was all running
on the cloud as well the Xbox cloud that
gets thrown around so much that's right
yeah so how does um how does that differ
from say a typical server that's used to
run back-end games the backend of games
the biggest difference is that we don't
have to configure it or pay for when
we're a small team you know we're
startup team making a game that's gold
dust you know we have the resources of
Microsoft on that back-end for us so
that it's been you know absolutely
critical to getting the game done cool
I've got a bunch of questions coming in
here if you have any questions at home
by all means put them in the chat or in
the comments and I got a question on my
own we have yeah you can read them there
if you want straight away I'm gonna skip
all the horrible ones um I have a
question of my own you guys obviously
showed up to beta pretty open about what
was in terms of content are you guys
planning to reveal any more stuff over
the next week because we're only like
seven days from launch at this stage in
terms of content
I think the Internet's handled that for
us yeah that's an interesting one Redis
I guess one there was a post a couple of
weeks ago and then over the weekend
there was kind of some leaks about well
supposedly about the turrets the various
maps there might be fifteen is the one
that's been thrown around and is any of
that stuff how true how do you guys look
at that stuff and go oh we got we've
been found out
is any information incorrect I haven't
read it all so I can't save some of it's
incorrect or not but I mean at some
point he just kind of have to throw up
your arms and say alright you got us it
is what it is yeah I know it's it's out
there fair enough um first question here
from Kenton ended what's your favorite
weapon to use in titanfall and what
Titan class do you use yourself alone I
can really use the shotgun hmm just
because it's fun and I'll go with an
Atlas most of the time you know it's
kind of a good balance so there was a
burn card in the beta to allowed you to
use the Strider that would come down
like straight away what did you guys
know when you were putting that stuff in
that because originally it was only the
Atlas was the only time you could
actually use in the game yeah you guys
aware of that soft it's yeah trying to
mess with people give them a little
taste
yeah there were over cards in there as
well and we decided let it go they're
pretty rare so not that many people got
to see them but when you did it's a cool
bonus one big question that's been
coming up a lot a tatter seven six five
six seven it's great username yeah asked
why did you step away from making a
single-player campaign to focus on this
campaign multiplayer concept
yeah it's about looking at where people
spend most of their time you know
generally people will burn through a
single campaign single-player campaign
as fast as they can you know you spend
five six hours and you know 80% of the
work goes into that and then you go and
spend a hundred hours in this thing that
gets you know it's bare-bones it's the
minimum you can get away with you know
for us it was about pushing the
boundaries of what multiplayer is so
let's take all that great single-player
stuff build up the world that world that
you're gonna spend a hundred hours in
should be the most full-featured so
that's single-player campaign how many
levels does that exist over do you play
it from both sides how does that work
you do play it from both sides it's it's
a short experience it's meant to be you
know a couple hours on each side and
then you know from there you don't have
to pick it again you can replay it you
don't have to you can just us straight
into regular multiplayer almost like a
sort of a tutorial for the the full game
that's gonna work that way you get
exposed to a lot of the mechanics that
way or is it the same leveling system as
a multiplayer it's same leveling system
as multiplayer it's here we have a
tutorial section so this it's not meant
to be training it's meant to be an
introduction to the lore the world the
story that you know to get you engrossed
in
and what we're trying to do Brinke so
you're gonna launch with a bunch of maps
there's a lot of it's a type of game
where you it evolves as you play and as
you level up and as you sort of learn
how to play the game and but like
looking months ahead two months three
months six months and do you guys have
any plans for like season packs DLC that
sort of stuff this is an EA game as well
it's being published by those guys that
seems to come hand in hand with some of
the stuff that they they are involved in
so are ye looking to do some of that
being pressurized to do it or how does
that work we're not being pressured to
do any of that at all we are going to do
we plan to do DLC to support the game
we're going to do DLC paid DLC we're
also going to do free updates we're
gonna add in you know there's things
that we want in the game that we didn't
get mm-hmm to ship in the final game so
we'll add like private matches and
things like that for free there will be
some paid DLC we're gonna do a season
pass just because it's you know if you
buy it upfront you get a deal it's not
we're not doing microtransactions yeah
so you know season passes just buy it
upfront and you get a better price house
to be good you were obviously part of
the team that's created Call of Duty
which ended up being sort of the seminal
first-person shooter of the last
generation and how important do you
think it is for titanfall that there is
this sort of community drive behind it
that there are certain people who are
championing it and for like the
long-term success of it you know I think
that's the longevity of the game is all
about the fans and helm you know how
well people take to it and how long they
can play it so I think that's you know
absolutely critical that we get that fan
base behind us and do you you've been
involved in obviously big games where
people get passionate about it either
way are you used to the sort of the
backlash that comes from it because
there was like I guess titanfall came
out when when the beta was dropped it
was sort of like a dead zone in the
games price as well and as suddenly it
was like titanfall overload in the way
and it was a sort of a weird back
reaction from a certain part of the
community about that are you sort of
used to that sort of stuff for the stuff
does that play into the way you guys
market this game or talk about the game
when when you see the sort of the
battling between either console fanboys
or series fanboys you know I didn't see
a lot of the the battling I need to stay
away from it I like to think I'm not
ignoring it
you know we see you know we watch a lot
of the response as we pay attention to
the community so you know we like to to
pay attention to that as kind of a
flavor I mean we have to design the game
based on what we think is gonna be fun
what we think is gonna be right and mr.
Jones John o7 asks how many maps will be
available at launch you guys talking
about that sort of stuff yet
well I we haven't talked about it but I
think you have so you can I believe 15
is the number that I heard flying around
on the internet the internet never lies
never yeah so does that do you think
that a lot of that stuff on that post n
is accurate from the machine gun turrets
to the the chain-link the rails and
whatnot I don't have to go look at that
okay all right no worries I got a game
I'd like to ask about the Xbox 360
version there's not been a whole lot
talked about when it comes to that I
know it's being made by Blue Point
that's right who have done a lot of
really good HD conversions of some last
gen games
I'm just curious you know is are all the
features that people are going to be
playing on the Xbox one and PC also
going to be present in that version
that's the goal I mean the game is
obviously not done yet they're right you
know they're doing a port of our game
yeah so they have to as we come in hot
you know we just started our day one
patch so they now have to take that and
integrate it into their game and you
know so they're naturally lag behind us
so the goal is to get it as close as
possible it obviously won't be exact
it's like you know on a powerful system
but a lot of people in that system
though you know I mean episome not I
haven't even upgraded to the next-gen
current gen consoles at this point so
that's actually what I'm eyeing I play
on PC a lot but for competitive
first-person shooters I like live and I
play on a 360 so I mean compliers
expected the same longevity of support
in terms of upgrades and patches that's
a really good question I mean I think
that's we'll have to sit down with the a
and talk about that I mean I my
assumption is yes but I don't know that
I'm the best person to speak for that
okay you guys have a lot of interesting
relationships here you're a new studio
and obviously there's a lot of talent
from from yourself to a lot of the folks
that I talked to a couple of weeks ago
that were worked on loads of different
projects across breadth of different
genres and platforms and but you're
still stuck in this interesting position
where you're partnering with the a from
a publishing perspective and then also
probably the most interesting
relationship is that with Microsoft did
you always
feel like you were going to create a
game that was going to be for one
specific console or was not a sort of a
business decision that comes from just
the realities of being a small team and
trying to create a game with this type
of scale yeah I mean when we started the
company that wasn't the goal I mean we
hadn't even been first on the next-gen
so as we started getting into
development we got you know told about
the console we talked to Microsoft first
just no hmm because of our relationship
with Microsoft looking at what we wanted
to make and what Microsoft was
delivering and being able to work with
them to kind of fashion what that was
yeah was appealing to us and and we
thought it made for the best game
possible was it always the plan to have
like a bundle to be that fundamental to
the early support of their new console
now the bundle stuff came much later
pretty yeah yeah it's not exciting it is
is it or is it like terrifying in one
way to be that to be that important to
to the early days of a new console like
that it's exciting what will you be
playing it on I play a lot on PC I also
play on Xbox one I go back and forth
between the two I mean some of it just
because I have to some of it because I
enjoy both yeah every Xbox 360 version a
little bit again we've been focusing on
the games that were developing so now I
think once we get this one out the door
we'll have that couple weeks to to turn
our eyes over to that awesome 360
version we have so many questions coming
in on not surprised at all I'm gonna
pick a couple more so in text on Twitter
asks what's the rationale behind the
burn card system and those do you feel
like it's doesn't overpower players in a
certain way or is it a way of teaching
them new ways of playing the game it's
actually it's more like power-ups so you
know we you want have this system where
things unlock over time and we do have
that as you're playing but now we can
give you these things that they might
overpower you but for a very short
amount of time it's one as you die
that's gone so it's a good way to get
things that you couldn't normally unlock
over you know playing the game because
it unbalances it and lets you kind of
give that to players and expose them to
new things it's it's a good fun powerup
system another question from Thamud
neusel asked was the idea of man against
machine warfare
fundamental at the beginning or was that
something that came later um it was
pretty fundamental at the beginning that
you know that how important it was kind
of varied from time to time but I know
it was it was really about that
the size discrepancy that man and
machine cat-and-mouse kind of game play
and that was really kind of core dope to
what we set out to do yeah when we were
talking to the guys from respawn down in
LA as well they brought up a load of
interesting sort of shining back to
games like Unreal Tournament and quake
that sort of fast and frenetic type of
multiplayer with those games that you
played at all like what type of
first-person shooters did you play that
kind of inferred the way you design
games I definitely played all the quake
3 was you know a game that I played for
a long time counter strikes unreal you
know even back to the doom hmm Peter and
you got any more questions for the man I
got up I'm gonna pull one out of here
from from the chassis
I am so curious about the blue point
production only because I'm a big fan of
theirs I know that that's not you can
have them on yeah I would love to where
are they based out of our Austin Austin
ok all down there a 1 trans design asks
how interactive will the creatures be in
titanfall this is another leak that came
via Mother Internet is there have you
got any anything to say about the
creatures we see flying around or is
there any interactivity there at all I
have nothing to say nothing to say
what's her deal see who knows if you're
a Titan for a day in real life why would
you do it it asks Tigers i-85 I would
step on the guy that leaked our
supposedly leaked you guys commercial
that was put out by Microsoft heavily
the one with the the dudes walking
industry with a big time
yeah blown-up stuff what was that like
putting together something like like how
how do you even pull yourself away from
the confident from creating a game to be
involved and not sort of there's an ad
agency that does it sorry just they show
us the ideas and we do some mint on it
rubber stamps
hopefully we work together harmoniously
in theory and James aku Gera asks a
question a lot of people have been
asking well titanfall remain an
exclusive thread it's franchise and do
you think this is the first step in a
franchise that you want to continue
making I don't think we can say
that we wanted to be a franchisee until
its successful first yeah if the first
game comes out and flops then I can say
it all I want and it means nothing is it
the type of that project that you you
you want to keep developing you know I
could see that there's definitely things
that we would like to to continue on so
I could see I could see a sequel working
absolutely what's it like this is the
first game you've released I guess it's
been four years since you founded
respawn you've been developing this game
for a probably closer to two and a half
or three is that correct yeah it's about
right a little bit a little over two
years a to two and a half what does it
really like developing time considering
you the sort of the torrid time you
would have had with all that happened in
the previous game but Activision why not
what's it like to actually have this
sort of the narrative of you as a
designer just be a better game again
like have you been looking forward to
next week for a couple of years yes and
now I mean there's definitely times
coming to it now where we are and and
being so close to it it feels really
good you know it feels like it has been
too long you know and how are you
looking forward to next week how do you
feel about reviews when they start
coming out when will you be say yeah
apparently you don't go any internet
very often release on review embargo day
will you be hittin the button or does
the the people who play the game are
they more important than the reviews the
people are definitely important the
reviews you know or also they kind of
set the tone for what people think of
the game so you kind of have to look at
both you know I like to say I won't be
crushed if it gets bad reviews as long
as people like it but I might be you've
got a good reputation to uphold at this
stage thank you good are you guys
nervous at all about mmm the first time
that servers go down and people won't be
able to play I'm sure that's the last
thing you want to happen but stuff
that's out of your control like guys
yeah but then there's a burden fall on
yeh or on Microsoft at that point but I
mean how do you how do you prepare for
something like that considering what
this game is yeah I mean I think it
falls on Microsoft but also it falls on
us because you know at the end of the
day it's our game it's it's not just
Microsoft's problem it is ours so you
know we take it very seriously and you
know while we hope that doesn't happen I
like how you say it's a foregone
conclusion when it's an unfortunately
things like that do happen I think you
know it'll depend on how we respond and
I think we need to
Spahn quickly and communicate to people
what's happening and let them know why
and let them know when things will be
fixed and and hopefully you know we are
we're all in it together just drop a
Titan at their door so they can use in
real life and Vince Zampella
thank you so much for coming on the show
and talking to us about titanfall one of
the biggest games coming out this year
and possibly the biggest games and the
biggest next-gen game that people have
been looking forward to as well and next
week yeah I just saying just don't screw
it up that's all I'm saying if you can't
you can just zip up that no one know
what the hell is going on right thanks
thanks very much for coming on really
appreciate it my pleasure